هدف للبرتغال في كاس العالم يقسم عالم كره
القدم رونالدو اللي سجل ولا فرنالدو سوا
على ابل وعراقيين عن سرقه القرن المضحك
المبكي اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
امس الاثنين كان في مباراه في دوري
المجموعات في كاس العالم بين البرتغال
والاوروجواي والمبارك كانت ناريه وانتهت
بفوز البرتغال بهدفين مقابل لا شيء وبكده
بتكون خلاص البرتغال نقدر نقول ضمنت
تاهلها لدور ال 16 لكن في تفصيله في
المباراه قال بالدنيا حرفيا وخصوصا على من
السطات وبين محبي ومتابعي الرياضه تحدانا
في اول اهداف البرتغال عام الجديد والجدل
هو حول مين اللي سجلوا فاللي صار انه
الكره طلعت من رجل او من رجل اللاعب
رونالدو واستقرت في المرمى رونالدو احتفل
والهدف انحسب وان حسب له
رونالدو تحديدا وشفنا كل القنوات والم
الواقع الناتله كمان كاتبه الهدف لرونالدو
لكن ما في دقائق الا وكانت كل المواقع
والقنوات مصححه الهدف وحسبته لفرنانديز
وقالت انه الكره اتضح انها ما لمسه راس
رونالدو ورونالدو كان ردت فعل في الملعب
وضحك في الملعب اللي تابع المباراه اكيد
شاف ولاحظ انه من لحظه منعاد الهدف وبدات
النقاشات انه يا جماعه فين لمسها وشيء
يقول ايه والمساء وشي يقول لا لكن عموما
التقنيات الجديده مخليه الكره الان فيها
سنسز وبطل قلت لمسه اي احد للكره وبحسب
الفيفا الكره ما لمسه راس رونالدو والهدف
ان حسب لي فرنانديز
لكن من وقت المباراه والدنيا مولعه في كل
من الصوت وبين المحللين والمختصين وحتى
المتابعين العاديين والسؤال هو مين سجل
الهدف فعليا والاراء مختلفه على فكره
والتفسيرات مختلفه كمان
وبعد ما قال كريستيانو رونالدو صاحب الهدف
لكن
خفيفه نفسه حسب واحد من اهم الرعاه
التكنولوجيين بالنسبه لكاس العالم 2022
اللي دائما بعد كل هدف بيجيب بعض
الاحصائيات مين اخر لاعب لمسها سرعه الكره
قد ايه اتجاه الكره قد ايه مين اللي حرك
مسار الكوره كل هذه الاموره فموقع الفيفا
اعتمد على ده في النهايه ان اعتمد ان خلاص
دلوقتي رونالدو ما قدرش الكوره لو انت
ركزت حتى على الهدف هتشوف انك كريستيانو
رونالدو حرفيا الكره ما بتغيرش اتجاهها
الكوره ما تغيرشارها ما فيش
تاتش او ادنى لمسه كريستيانو رونالدو انا
شايف الهدف المفروض يحتسب كريستيانو
رونالدو صحيح للوحده الاولى لما همم اللي
عدى الاولانيه ظهرت كان يبدو ان هو لما
لبسهاش ولكن في اعداد كثير همم ظهرت بعد
المباراه اوضاعت انك كريستيانو ولا ماسك
الكوره حتى لو لمسه بسيطه والهدف بيحتسب
لاخر لاعيب لها الناس الكوره همم نقطه
ثانيه برده انا شايفها مهمه في الجدل همم
اللي حاصل على الهدف انه بشكل او اخر
كريستيانو وس في الهدف لانه لولا تحركه
ومحاولته لعب الكوره كان الحارس عرفت تحرك
على الكره العرضيه بسهوله ويقدر يمسكها
ولكن محاوله كريستيانو لعبه الكوره خدعت
الحارس وتسببت في الاخر ان الكره تدخل هدف
وجهه نظري الشخصيه انه صح الصور بعضها
بتبدو كانه لمسها لكن هذه الكره الموجوده
كره اديداس فيها حساس عالي التقنيه بالمس
وبقيس اقل لمسه بتصير فلو فعلا لمسها كانت
الكره اعطت اشاره لمسها لكن بما انه
القرار كان بعدم لمسه الكره فهذا معناه
انه رونالدو فعليا ما اثر ابدا لا عن سرعه
ولا اتجاهه ولا اي شيء بالكره فهذا معناه
ايضا انه رونالدو لمسها وهنا بصير الهدف
فعليا
هذه وجهه النظر لكن ايضا هذا الهدف كان
مستحيل يتسجل بدون رونالدو يعني عرضيه
بدون رونالدو يطلع ويشوش على الحارس ويلفت
انتباه الحارس اكيد كان حارس في كاس
العالم مع الاوروجواي حيث يتولى رونالدو
جزء من الهدف لكن ليس من سجل
اعتقد انه كريستيانو
واعتقد انه يعني شعره يعني شعر كريستيانو
يعني فاعتقد انه هو الحق زاد انه الاتحاد
البرتغالي قاعد يضغط على فيفا انه يحسب
الهدف له كريستيانو
خليني اقول لكم مشاهدينا ان الجدل والنقاش
مو مقتصر على الناس المتفرجين فحتى جوه
المنتخب نفسه الموضوع عام البلبله فاول
شيء صار انه الاعلامي بيرس مورجان واللي
مو من زمان عمل لقاء مع رونالدو قال انه
رونالدو بلغوا شخصيا انه راسه لمست الكره
يعني هو اللي سجل الهدف واللاعب فرنانديز
نفسه لي الصحفيين بعد المباراه قال انه
احتفلوا كانه رونالدو سجل الهدف وانه كده
شاف الملعب وانه هدفه اصلا كان يمرر
رونالدو الكره لكن قال كمان المهم انه
فزنا بغض النظر مين سجل هنا لازم نذكر انه
فرنانديز رجع سجل الهدف الثاني
للبرتغال من ضربه جزاء على فكره لكن
الموضوع كل ماله بيكبر يا جماعه فجاه شفنا
التقارير عن انه الاتحاد البرتغالي هيراسل
الفيفا رسميا بادله انه الهدف من حق
رونالدو والكره لمسته ورجعنا شفنا تاكيدات
بعدها من الفيفا انه التكنولوجيا اكدت بما
لا يسير اي شكل انه الكره ما لمسه رونالدو
وترى يعني غريب شويه الموضوع او غريب شويه
في المواد الموضوع جماعه انه الاتحاد
البرتغالي يراسل الفيفا عشان يحسب هدف
لرونالدو بدل فرنانديز يعني الاثنين
لاعبينك وفي نفس المنتخب اشمعنا جاءت
لنفسك تثبت انه الهدف ليه رونالدو اتجاه
هناك والتحليلات تطول بس علشان نحطكم في
الصوره كامله لازم نذكركم بكذا شيء اولهم
الازمات اللي بيعانيها رونالدو في مسيرته
الاحترافيه فسخ عقده مع مانشستر يونايتد
من كم يوم وفكره انه واحد من اهم لاعبين
الكره في العالم حاليا بدون نادي وغير
مرغوب وثاني شيء وهو الاهم انه رونالدو
اللي بيشارك في الخامس كاس عالم واللي
يسجل في كل الدورات اللي شارك فيها بيسعى
ونفسه ومنع عينه قبل ما يعتزل انه يحقق
كاس العالم بلاده لو في هذا المونديال حتى
الان ما سجل الا هدف واحد فقط ومن ضربه
جزاء كان في هدف ثاني سجله لكن اللغه بسبب
انه نحسب فاول ضده يعني وعموما حتى الان
افضل شيء حققته البرتغال في كاس العالم
كيف 2006 لما حصلت المركز الرابع رونالدو
اذا نفسه يضيف كاس العالم لقائمه انجازاته
الحاليه خاصه وانه الان عمره 37 سنه ومع
انه ما اعلن انه هذا اخر كاس عالم لو
رسميه لكن يعني متوقع هذا الشيء في كاس
العالم الجاي هيكون عنده 41 سنه
وبالمناسبه هو اعلى في مقابلته مع البيس
مورجن انه لو كاس العالم هذا كسبه في
حيعتزل يعني واضح جدا لانه هذه البطوله هي
الشيء الاساسي اللي مخليه يكمل اللعب احنا
التفاعل لكم حبينا نعرف ارائكم انتم
مشاهدينا بما انه على
الاغلب اذا مو كلكم متابع له كاس العالم
ويحضرته المباراه بعد الجدل رجعته شفته
الهدف سالناكم انه مين برايكم سجل هذا
الهدف اجابتكم جاءت كالتالي 60% شايفين
حسب والهدف
لفيرنانديز واربعين في الميه تجريبا
شايفينه لرونالدو
الماسك اخباره اليوم ناريه في ماسك خلاص
اعلن الحرب على ابل رسميا بعد ما احد
متابعينه قال انه احتمال ابل وجوجل يحذف
تويتر من متاجرهم وانه ماسك لازم ينتج
هاتف جديد واختارد ماسك وقال انه ما
بيتمنى يصير هذا الشيء بس لو صار راح ينتج
هذا البديل يبدا انه التلميحات صارت واقع
وماسك
اللي بتسيطر بطبيعه الحال على اختيار
التطبيقات المسموحه في مجرها
لانه ابل هددته بازاله تويتر التطبيقات
وما تم اخباره طبعا متجر تطبيقات عبر
الطريق الوحيد لتوزيع البرامج على اجهزه
ايفون واذا تم واا قبل كمان يعني واذا تم
ازاله تويتر ستفقد الشبكه الاجتماعيه احدى
من الصوت التوزيع الرئيسيه واشار ماسك انه
ابل اوقفت اغلب اعلانات على تويتر وتسائل
انه هل ابل بيكره وحريه التعبير في امريكا
وارفق هذه التغريده بالثاني عمل فيها منشن
للرئيس التنفيذي للابل تم كوك وسالوه ايش
اللي جالس بيصير هنا ومو بس كده ماسك نزل
في سيل من التغريدات هجوم في ابل ونقد
واستفسارات فقال مثلا انها بتحضريبه سريه
30% سنويا على كل شيء بتشتروا من اب ستور
ونشر استطلاع سال فيه الناس انه برايكم هل
ابل لازم تنشر جميع اجراءات الرقابه اللي
اتخذتها واللي بتاثر على العملاءها هنا
كانت النتيجه 85% نعم و15% لا
خذ العينات بس من السلخ اللي سلخ وماسك
كدا مقتطفات يعني يعني حتى لما مغرد كتب
له انه لو في احد قادر يدخل في صراع مع
ابل وعنده فرصه يكسبها فهو الماسك لكنه
بحاجه لحلفاء ماسك رد على التغريده وقال
له انه اي دعم محل تقدير امامكم هذه
الانتقادات والتغريدات شركه ابل ملتزم
الصمت وما ردت ابدا على اي شيء ولا حتى
تعلقت لكن التداول معلومات انه في الشلل
اللي هو بيشرف على مراجعه التطبيقات في
ابل حذف حسابه من تويتر في وقت سابق من
هذا الشهر بعد ما تولع ماسك منصبه تمام
ينضم الينا عبر الزوم المحرر التقني في
انجلترا العربيه عبد الله السبع اهلا فيك
معنا عبد الله يعني الحرب على الماسك
جالسه شغاله من نواحي كثيره يبدو انه ابتل
الان احدث منظمين ليش يوقفوا اعلانات
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه على هذه الاستضافه
لازم نعرف معلومه ان خلاف لهم ماسك مع ابل
تراب مو بس هذه الفتره تراي لهم ماسك
عندها مشاكل في السنوات الماضيه وكانت
عندها مشاكل مختلفه مع ابل يعني قبل فتره
كانت تسلا تعاني من مشاكل وممكن تدخل في
مرحله الكلاس وحاول يعرض الشركه على الابل
والاسف ما تمت البيعه من بعدها الى ما كان
عنده تحفظ كبير على هذه الشركه يعني
بعطيكم معلومه مثلا سيارات تسلا حتى الان
ما تدعم نظام ابل للسيارات وفي قيود معينه
كده يعني
اصلا القلوب مليانه القلوب مليانه
والخلافات ما بينهم ترى ابدا يعني ما هي
على قولتهم بسيطه لكن انا اختلف معي لهم
ماسك يوم قال ضريبه سريه على التطبيقات
هذه الضريبه معينه او ايضا تاخذ حصتها من
متاجر من التطبيقات اللي تكون موجود في
متاجر التطبيقات وشقق للمعلوميه صارت ما
حد شركات الالعاب المشهوره اللي كانت
موجوده على منصه ابل رفضت تدفع 30% واضل
على طول اقساطها الماده والتطبيقات ولا
صارت موجوده وهذه الشركه حاليا تعاني من
مشاكل مختلفه بسبب استبعادها متجر ابل
للاسف خسرت عبد الكبير من المستخدمين
والتجاره والمستخدمين الى الالعاب بديله
خساره
الحين هو واضح انه يعني بده يحارب على اي
دولار عشان يزيد اربعه واضح ان الموضوع
عنده مهم جدا لهذه الدرجه طيب غير هذه
الخناقه يكون ابل انه توقف اعلاناتها هذا
موقف سياسي نوعا ما او هذا موقف يعبر عن
عدم ايمانه في ال المصري
لكن لازم نعرف معلومه ترى مو بس اصل وقفت
الاعلانات كثيره في السوق الامريكي وقفت
اعلانات في تويتر
من اسلوب ال الماسك عبروا عن عدم رضاهم من
انه يقول حريه التعبير
عندك
على تويتر فلذلك الموضوع ترى بسيط جدا وما
هو متعلق في الدعاياته وهو متعلق في نسبه
ال 30 انا اشوف وهو رئيس شخص يحتمل الصواب
ويحتمل الخطا وهو ان من حق اضل اخذ 30%
تخيل انك انت تروح الى مول مشهور معروف كل
الزوار
وتتاخد محل داخل هذا المول لكن رافض انك
تدفع ايجار داخل هذا الموت هذا اللي صاير
الان في متجر التطبيقات واحد من اكثر
المتاجر اه في عالم التطبيقات واحد من
اكثر المتاجر ربحا في عالم متاجر
التطبيقات فاذا حطيت تطبيقك في حقل الشركه
لا تاخذ 30% لانها توفر بلاتور معينه انها
توفر نظام دفع معين يعطيك معلومه ومعلومه
هذه معروفه وممكن نختم فيها قبل تقطعيني
انه الان نفس التطبيق اللي موجود على
تطبيقات او متجر ابل ونفس التطبيق موجود
على متجر اندرويد ارباح التطبيق على ابل
اعلى بكثير من ارباحها على الاندرويد لانه
مستخدمين افضل يدفعون عكس مستخدمين
الاندرويد على مصادر مجانيه وممكن يركبونه
بطريقه قانونيه لتوفير الدفع فلذلك
تطبيقات حلوه كثيره وارباح مختلفه طائله
جدا
لاسباب اخرى غير اللي جالس هو يعني انها
صراحه يعني
هو وكيلافات موجوده ما بيني وبين ابل
ولازم نعرف ان ماهي اول مره
راحت وعملت الخطوه هذه يا سيدي قال لهم
طيب اوكي حلينا مشكله ال 30% خدوا 30%
حقكم عادي
واذا راحوا استمروا وشالوا التطبيق من
المتجر ما تعتقد انه رده الفعل حتكون
كبيره جدا من الناس خصوصا تطبيق بحجم
تويتر واستخداماته سواء الاخباريه من
السياسيين وما الا ذلك
فيها واستخدمها لكن ما توقع يوصل الموضوع
الى حذف التطبيق من متجر التطبيقات لانه
لا حساسيه كبيره واضل اساسا تعتمد عليها
يعني
اساسا يعتمد على تويتر تويتر
مختلفه فلذلك اتوقع لن يصل الموضوع الى
الحذف لكن اني انا اولوح في وسيله قد اضغط
عليك حتى ترضخ لقوانين الخاصه فيني ولا
تسبب لي ازعاج هذا اللي يتوقع الاصاله
السير تويتر منصه للتلويح والتهديد لكل
الاطراف عشان تفهم الرساله قبل ما يصير
مشكله طيب نحنا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا عبر الزوم المحرر التقني في اند
فندم العربيه عبد الله السبع شكرا لك عبد
الله
[موسيقى]
من جديد في العراق ما في خبر شاغل
العراقين اكثر من مستجدات سرقه القرن زي
ما صار اسمها وهي الفضيحه اللي تكشفت في
اكتوبر لما ان كشفت سرقه مليارين ونصف
نعم نعم زين سمعته هذا هو المبلغ
من اموال الضرائب الجديد في القصه
واسترداد جزء من المبلغ المسروق
واثنين
خلينا نقول مليون مليار دينار عراقي اللي
هو بعاد ال125 مليون دولار المليارين ونصف
اللي انسرقوا ومعاه كمان تم الافراج عن
احد المتهمين علشان يجيب باقي
زهير جاسم
مالك شركتي القانت والمبدعون
هذا المتهم اعتراف انه اخذ التريليون
و618 الان سلم
182 مليار مكسور
وهذه الدفعه الاولى تم الاتفاق
بين محكمه التحقيق الكرخ الثانيه مع هذا
المتهم نور زهير على جدول الاسترداد كامل
المبلغ اللي هو تريليون
670 مليون دينار
حتى يسلم كل المبلغ
سيصدر القاضي المختص
امر باطلاق سراحه بكفاله يسلم الاموال
ويبقى الاجراء عند القبر
هنا ندعو
المتهمين
الصادره بحقهم اوامر قبض في هذه القضيه
الى تسليم انفسهم وتسليم المبالغ المسروقه
وسنعمل مع القضاء على مساعدتهم بالاجراءات
القضائيه وفوق ما يسمح به القانون
ظهور رئيس الوزراء برزم الفلوس حوالين
واثر جد الواسع فانا ستنكرت المنظر وناس
استنكرت الافراج عن متهم وناس ثانيه قالت
طب ما هو لو فضل محبوس ما حيرجع شيء وناس
تقول اللي رجع يده ب 5% من المسروق وناس
تقول يا حسره على البلد اللي اكلها الفساد
ونقاش طويل عريض شغال واللي بتسال كيف
ممكن ينسرق مليارين ونص دولار في اللي صار
انه تدقيق داخلي لوزاره الماليه العراقيه
في الهيئه العامه للضرائب كشف الاختلاف
التفاصيل كثيره ومعقده لكن الخلاصه انه
الفاسدين اعملوا خمسه شركات وهميه وحولوا
لها المبالغ هذه كلها من وداع ضريبيه
لشركات يعني
وقاحه على اعلى مستوى تدرس بصراحه يعني
فحولوا
1000 2000 مليار ونص دولار والموضوع انكشف
لما اشتكت شركه نفط انها بالطالب بوذيعتها
وما عرفت تحصلها وبدات الفضيحه وسهرت
استقالات واقالات وتدقيق وتحقيق رسمي وعود
بالوصول للمبلغ وتقديم المتهمين للعداله
والجديد اللي عرضناه لكم هو اليوم يعني
اول المستجدات في التحقيق الافراج عن
المتهم عشان رجع شويه من اللي سرقوا وعود
انه يرجع الباقيه طيب العراقيين من اكتوبر
موقفه كلام في الموضوع وتعليقات على فتاه
المبلغ حسره على كم الفساد سخريه من الوضع
المضحكه المبكي وكاميرات تفاعلكم رصدت لكم
من الشارع العراقي بعض الاصدقاء
فضيحه القرن تعتبر فهي تعتبر قطره في بحر
محيط من السرقات التي حصلت للشعب العراقي
اخراج نبضات من الفلوس السوداني طلع نبضات
من الفلوس شنو راح يخش بكيس الشعب
بالنسبه للقضيه اللي كشفت مؤخرا بخصوص
سرقه 3 مليار استرجاع مليار فقط
بالعراق
سنوات
هنا وهناك بالوقت اللي احنا نشوف الشعب
العراقي كثيره معاناتها مجريه يعني بس
بالعراق يعني سارق مليارات يطلعونه
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم انا
نعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]